guess what bachelorette villain Chad  Johnson used to have a tinder profile  and it's just as Chad tactic as you'd  assume you're welcome  Here I am here's a screenshot of Chad's  former profile on website the privy  according to the author of the post she  swiped left on the 28 year old a year  ago but now that he's bad boy Chad and  all she wanted to share a screenshot of  his profile it reads quote you're gonna  have to deal with me being a workaholic  realtor I go out once a month maybe and  I work out six days a week you probably  have a better chance of winning the  lottery to be honest now for anyone out  there who doubts this glorious profile  actually once belonged to me Chad well  he confirmed it himself on Twitter he  wrote on Saturday quote fine you caught  me but we both know you swiped right  hashtag tinder winner hashtag the  Bachelorette hashtag no lottery win for  you all I'm doing is calling things like  they are